I'm Laurin I read a column for GQ called
ask a real live lady and I'm here to
answer all the questions you'd feel too
stupid to ask a woman you actually know
this week's question is from Peter in
Nebraska he writes dear GQ sex advice
lady that's not my name it's a real live
lady should I be Smythe life more on the
TV show girls or Game of Thrones well
let me ask you this what turns you on
more is it half a dozen dragons chopping
on a blonde ladies tits or coming in a
woman's armpit and your apartment that
looks like it belongs to a CSI Berber
consider making complicated love/hate to
a terrorist
I hear al Zawahiri is still alive he
actually is really nice puppy-dog eyes
but what about Mad Men for joyless
pathological infidelity or pit bulls and
parolees bestiality in prison sacks why
the heck not
the point is TV relationships aren't
good relationships even Mike and Carol
Brady have their dirty laundry good
relationships are pretty unwatchable in
fact a good relationship is cracking a
beer and watching a bad relationship on
Netflix with someone you love so maybe
the question you should be asking is
should I be watching girls or Game of
Thrones with the person I'm dating or
having sex with the answer to that is
EEMA thrones obviously
you